PICKED UP SEVENTH REBOUND.
YOUNG ON THE ATTACK.
LOOKING FOR SOMEONE.
SIXERS DENIED.
FLOATER THUS FAR.
SIMMONS ON THE WAY.
SIMMONS THROWS IT DOWN.
NOPE, THE FOUL CALLED PRIOR TO.
>> Jim: GOING REVIEW, TO.
>> Brian: CLEAR PATH OR NOT,
THEY'LL CHECK THAT.
SO THEY'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THIS
HERE.
>> Referee: RULES ON THE FLOOR
IS A CLEAR PATH FOUL.
IT WILL NOW BE UNDER REVIEW.
>> Jim: GO BACK TO THAT LAST
PLAY BY TRAE YOUNG.
AGAIN, TRIED TO GET THE BALL IN
TO CLINT CAPELA ON THE BASELINE
FACING EMBIID.
THEY PROBABLY WOULD HAVE BEEN
BETTER SERVED TO PULL IT OUT,
KNOWING THAT CAPELA, NOT ONLY IN
THIS GAME BUT LAST GAME AS WELL,
HAS BEEN HAVING PROBLEMS
FINISHING AROUND THE RIM.
SEE, RIGHT HERE.
ALL RIGHT, NOW YOU WANT TO DUMP
IT INSIDE.
I GET THE IDEA AND CONCEPT, BUT
UNDERSTAND WHO YOU'RE PASSING IT
TO AND WHO'S GUARDING THEM.
NOW HENCE, NOT A SOLID
POSSESSION.
GET IT BACK OUT.
TURNOVER HAPPENS.
>> Brian: CALLED A CLEAR PATH
FOUL.
TWO FREE THROWS IN POSSESSION IF
IT STAYS THAT WAY.
NATE McMILLAN IMPLORING HIS
TEAM, AND YOU KNOW THAT
CONVERSATION'S ABOUT DEFENSE.
THAT'S WHERE EVERYTHING STARTS
WITH McMILLAN WHO'S BROUGHT THAT
DEFENSIVE TENACITY TO THIS TEAM.
>> Referee: AFTER REPLAY REVIEW,
THAT'S A CLEAR PATH FOUL.
TWO SHOTS.
>> Jim: TWO SHOTS AND POSSESSION
HERE.
I AGREE WITH YOU, BUT RIGHT NOW
OFFENSIVELY THEY HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT WAYS TO GET SOME EASY
BASKETS, TO GET MORE CLEAN
LOOKS.
THEY HAVE HAD LOOKS BEHIND
THREE, BUT THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO KNOCK IT IN.
BUT NOW GET THE LITTLE BASKETS
THAT CAN HELP THE MOMENTUM
BUILD.
THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN THEM AND
HAVEN'T GOTTEN ANY EXCITING
PLAYS YET.
>> Brian: WELL IT WAS ON THIS
FLOOR IN GAME ONE.
AS SIMMONS MISSES THE FIRST.
HAWKS MADE 23 POINTERS IN GAME
ONE.
AND THEY HAVE THE SHOOTERS TO DO
THAT.
WE SEE IT EVERY YEAR, THE RIPS
STARTING TO TIGHTEN UP WHEN YOU
GET INTO THE PLAYOFFS.
THIS CROWD TRYING TO HELP OUT
BEN SIMMONS.
HE MISSES AGAIN.
HE'S MISSED FIVE CONSECUTIVE
FREE THROWS NOW AFTER HE MADE
HIS FIRST.
AND IT WILL BE SIXER BALL ON THE
CLEAR PATH FOUL.
SIMMONS NOW 1 FOR 6.
HE DOES HAVE THREE POINTS.
HE'S GOT FIVE ASSISTS IN THE
GAME.
HE WAS MAKING A RUN AT A
TRIPLE-DOUBLE IN GAME FOUR AND
DISAPPEARED IN THE SECOND HALF.
HE HAD JUST ONE FIELD GOAL
ATTEMPT.
HE SAID HE NEEDS TO BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE HERE IN GAME FIVE.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO FOUL
SIMMONS AND PUT HIM BACK AT THE
LINE.
BACK DOWN TO STEPHANIE READY.
>> Stephanie: I KNOW THERE WAS
SOME CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT
OFFICIALS WERE DISCUSSING.
THEY WERE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO THE TIME-OUT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN CHARGED TO.
IT WAS CHARGED TO PHILLY, SO
THEY WENT FROM SIX TO FIVE
TIME-OUTS.
>> Brian: THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SIMMONS KNOCKS DOWN A FREE
THROW.
YEAH, I WAS CURIOUS TO KNOW WHAT
THAT WAS ABOUT.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
THIS IS THE WAY